[Musik]
dass sie bereits im haus zu tode kamen
davon gehen wir immer noch fest aus seit
einem jahr ist rebecca reusch aus berlin
spurlos verschwunden wir wissen von
einem foto das sie noch an eine freundin
geschickt hat am morgen vor ihrem
verschwinden der schwager florian er
gilt weiterhin als hauptverdächtigen wir
hatten durch die krise aufnahmen
hinweise darauf dass möglicherweise die
leiche von rebecca dorthin verbracht
worden sein könnte und haben deswegen
die suche im vorwiegend auf diesen
bereich konzentriert
[Musik]
um entweder er ist besonders geschickt
entweder hat unglaubliches glück oder
ist vielleicht auch gar nicht der täter
das wissen wir ebenfalls nicht ganz
genau das letzte davon gehen wir zwar im
moment nicht aus aber wir können moment
auch nichts anderes machen das gesamte
interview mit dem ermittelnden
staatsanwalt im fall rebecca neusch
sehen sie auf bild.de mit bild plus
[Musik]